we're going to talk about today is
before we break into the steps about
becoming a product manager and the
product manager you want to be we'll
talk a little bit about what a product
manager is and a little bit about my
story and perspective for this
presentation
all right so jumping in what is a
product manager
was a product manager so you probably
either you know maybe some of you are
product managers maybe you have heard
about product management the you know
they're the CEO of the product if you've
heard that maybe you work in a company
and product manager seem to be doing a
lot of presentations or maybe making
decisions leading meetings and you're
kind of like I want to do that I want to
lead
um maybe you looked up the salary fair
enough you know these are all fair
enough ways to be interested in like
what what the heck is this
um so but what is a product manager
really
um product managers are really just here
to build amazing solutions to hard
problems or just delighting customers so
product managers are here to solve
problems for people
um and they're also here to you know
product managers don't just just
um
build Solutions but they have to also
Define the um sort of parameters of what
that
um what where they're going to go after
the solution Define what success means
and then achieve it and then do it in
the real world so product manager ship
product it's not theoretical and just
stress strategy we get work out into the
world and we test it and that means we
have to be practical and work within
real world constraints so it's a really
fantastic and interesting role and I'm
just going to give you a few examples of
some products that I've been sort of
thrilled by recently just to cover the
gamut of a few things that you could do
so this first one I use uh Capital One
as my main credit card
these rewards I never really use them
they kind of like were in the background
and
Amazon being being Amazon we're like hey
we could apply these toward your
purchase so I go to buy a stuffed animal
for my baby and it's basically free
which is amazing so that's a very
amazony thing to do so that just made me
stoked
um this is a sort of silly version
there's this thing called poolsweet.fm
that's just a website where you can
listen to cool tunes and feel like
you're in Palm Springs
um super fun and catchy this was
something that solved a really actually
hard and serious problem for me so we've
been struggling with sleep training with
the baby it was really really hard to
get a hold of sleep trainer it was
expensive and I discovered this app that
I actually had through work that would
let me just talk to a certified sleep
trainer like that day and it blew my
mind um solved a huge problem for us
really helped unlock some solutions it
was really helpful for me last one for
something completely different if you
have ever done
um you know anything with VR with an
Oculus or other sort of VR headset it's
super fun and interesting I don't know
if metaverse is the future or not but I
do know that playing Billy eilish on
beat saber is extremely fun
um so all of these examples are just
examples of different products that
product managers are behind and work
with teams to create these really great
experiences so how do you become one of
these that's what we're going to talk
about today
okay so here's a little bit about my
story to kind of show you my perspective
and sort of where I'm coming from with
this presentation
so I graduated in 2007 yes I am an elder
geriatric Millennial with an English
major from a college that no one had
ever heard of I really didn't care at
the time I just wanted to be a writer
and live on a boat that was like my main
aspiration in life
um in 2008 the recession hit I had
luckily gotten a job as an editor
I tried to quit that job I begged for it
the day after because it was the
recession that was like shoot I should
probably have work so I'm glad I did but
I really didn't like that job and it
took me a long time to get out of it and
to figure out what I wanted to do I
applied to literally hundreds of jobs it
was really hard
um by the time 2012 ran came around I
finally found someone I really connected
with named Marnie who helped me get a
six-week contract job as a technical
writer that at a startup that turned
into a full-time job thanks to her help
for advocating for me problem was once I
became a technical writer I really
wasn't satisfied with just writing
content about product I didn't want to
write directions for how to make a
product make sense when it just didn't
make sense in the interface so I kept
hunting the product managers down being
like can we change this what's going on
here why'd you make this decision can we
try this one instead and it just kind of
became clear to some of my colleagues
and I didn't even really know this at
the time that I was thinking like a
product manager somebody encouraged me
to apply for an open entry-level PM role
at my at the company at the time gave me
a copy of Marty kagan's inspired I read
the book and almost fell off my chair I
was like this is what I want to do with
my life I didn't even know this was a
job and I worked really hard to and
studied for That interview
barely got it and then barely hung on
for my life because I really didn't have
any experience at the time other than my
expertise in this domain of the startup
um I really hope that what I've learned
over the years while up leveling myself
and gaining the information that I
needed to succeed in product can really
help you all I also um you know in my
role as VP of product at a startup
called people Grove as well as a manager
at Udacity I've learned a lot about
hiring and interviewing entry level and
intern level PM so I have a little bit
of perspective on what hiring managers
might be looking for
now I work for Twitter and with writers
and editors and Publishers and despite
all the craziness in the news I'm still
excited to work there so
um All Right Moving On
okay some notes before getting started
the audience for the first few steps are
more about breaking into product the
second and more about up leveling so
this is kind of about becoming the
product manager that you want to be at
the end of the day grain of salt of
course these steps are all my opinion
colored by my journey
um there's a lot of ways to do this this
is just sort of my perspective and then
you know behind the bubble I can't move
it or it'll stop my slides um these are
all free they're meant to be Scrappy and
kind of a lot of work but they're also
steps that anyone can do without having
to pay a bunch of money to get an MBA or
expensive coaching
okay getting started break into product
steps one and two get started somewhere
as my writing coach used to say if you
had writer's block just get started
somewhere just start something and
that's what I would say to folks who are
struggling to figure out how to break
into product just be a product manager
just do it there are a million different
ways to start a website a product
physical product
um you maybe you have some data that you
found you know there's literally
publicly available data about like
weather and about humans that you could
put a front end in front of with air
table I mean the literally Endless
Possibilities a lot of times you know
when I've interviewed folks for
internships or PM roles and they tell me
they started their own thing they kind
of apologize for it only five people
used it and I'm always thrilled I'm
always like oh thank God this is amazing
this is somebody who's you know really
wants to be a PM you can just see it
through their action and it's inspiring
so just do it start your own thing
similarly create something from scratch
so the crew product management is a is a
um a very creative discipline and it's a
craft so if you are have an idea for a
screenplay you want to organize a
community volunteering effort you want
to start a meet up all of those things
will contribute to your ability to think
creatively and to build something from
scratch so ship it get something done
and that will also give you some
ammunition in the interview to stand out
from the crowd and also just give you a
little bit of confidence so that you can
start kind of figuring out what it means
to be a product manager
all right next steps so these are kind
of similar to the first ones but they're
more about forming your perspective
where you want to go with it so many
different Avenues and sometimes it's
hard to pick which one you want to go
into so this can help you hopefully in
your search
so the first one find a problem that you
really have to solve something you're
really interested in here are some
examples maybe you created a hack
um could be physical you tape something
up because you didn't like the way your
configured your room was configured
could be digital could be emotional
maybe you solved some really hard
problem and you could create training
around that
um what did you hack what's prom did you
solve number two what annoyed you what
could you fix it could be a little thing
it could be a big thing how do you how
would you solve that problem
number three why do you see Injustice in
the world the world is very unjust there
are so many ways to lift others up how
can you work to fix that problem in the
world uh number four maybe this isn't
something that you would necessarily
think of but a friend of mine actually
created a product out of something fun
that we all came up with as a group
um a couple hours into hanging out share
your your fun idea with the world
um I think that's one thing that really
surprised me about product management is
if you find something amazing others
probably will too so what problem do you
have to solve this can give you a
perspective into what companies you want
to interview for when you are
interviewing for them you probably will
have done some more thinking around this
problem which will really help you stand
out
next product managers take a lot of
information and synthesize it it's very
important to read a lot think a lot
discuss with others so that you can push
back and have a perspective you're going
to spar with Engineers it's important to
be able to take a lot of information in
have a perspective about it and be able
to stand up for it so have fun with it
build a list of books podcast articles
I'm going to share a bunch of stuff but
I can I'm happy to share
um you know my own favorites you can
also Google it read the news
um product managers work within like I
said earlier work within a context a
real world context it's really helpful
to know what's going on in the world
even 10 minutes read the news every day
watch TV have some fun with content
consume stories talk about what they
mean with people have fun reading and
consuming content is actually more
important than it seems
okay become an expert so I've already
sort of covered this but becoming an
expert I mean back to when I applied for
my PM role at the beginning at the start
of I was at I I was an expert in the
company in email technology because I
was writing about it as part of the my
technical writing that's one example you
know if you're especially when you're
applying to an entry level role say it's
a gaming company are you a gamer are you
an expert in that because you play it
all the time that's an example too just
become an expert in something find
something that you're passionate about
and that will lead you to more success
and also more satisfaction in your life
in my opinion
all right steps six and seven if this is
a little bit of a funny transition
because it's like I want to be a PM how
do I get the job and I'm like get the
job so this is kind of a crossing the
chasm moment
um
in my experience there are four General
paths that people tend to take when
becoming a product manager they do what
I did get a job at a startup become a
trusted expert and then apply for an
open PM job in their company a lot of
people I know have done that they've
joined an account management they've
joined in support technical writing
engineering there's so many different
ways web development marketing I've
known a lot of PMS who've come from
other roles in their startup
um a lot of startup Founders end up as
PM so they are entrepreneurial they
started their own product and then they
either got acquired or just kind of
became PMS realized that that's that's
the role that they want
Engineers end up often becoming PMS
because they maybe they get specs that
they want to improve they start
improving them and then they realize
actually I'm enjoying this role more and
they become a PM from there
the fourth one is one that I feel like
people often want to do which is getting
um you know an associate or an
entry-level PM job straight out of an
MBA or college like getting sort of
placed in a role that one in my
experience seems a lot more rare and a
lot harder to do you can do it but if
you aren't in an MBA or you know
honestly in some ways a top college
there's a lot of other ways to get
yourself into the role but that is that
is one valid way of course as well
so my suggestion this is maybe a little
controversial but this is the way that I
do it
um I think the easiest way to become a
PM is not actually necessarily applying
directly to be a PM it's actually kind
of going in from the side so joining a
com a tech company or a startup in a
role that suits your passions so I
joined as a technical writer again I
didn't mean to do this going in but you
could join in marketing you could join
in doing a lot of things that you're
interested in to be clear do a good job
make sure that you're a good colleague
like do your Do Your Role maybe you'll
fall in love with that role too that's
also great but if you still want to
become a PM become a trusted expert in
the company show creativity passion
leadership expertise and then a role
opens just go for it and just keep
trying
um after you've been at a startup for a
while even if you can't necessarily get
that role in your company I have seen
people once they've built expertise and
say education or whatever it is that
they're working in pivot into an entry
level PM role at another comp company
with that same expertise so it's still
valuable to be at a startup even if you
can't necessarily move into a PM role at
that startup
okay this is pivoting a little bit into
more of the how do you grow in your role
but once you're once you have you know
started as a PM I would suggest that you
try out a few different roles so I have
a few here but there's there's so many
different types of product manager so
I have a growth Pam you can't really see
that there but that's kind of about you
know maybe you have an e-commerce funnel
you're trying to get people to purchase
so how can you take a metric and make it
go up into the right what what sort of
changes can you do to the website a b
testing Etc it's pretty fun um and
analytical platform PMS this is more
technical so how do you build the
platform the other is built off of so
this could be a Content management
system that Engineers use it could be a
product like Shopify that that Shoppers
I'm sorry Merchants use to sell their
products
um zero to one PM this is about growing
a startup so either start your own
startup or you could join a startup
within a startup and start something
from scratch
there's a lot of ways to do it and it's
I do think that because it's kind of
easy to switch into different roles
trying out these different roles can be
really good for your career and for
understanding what you actually like um
out of the product management role
okay Next Step Up level
so
um these next steps are kind of about
you know maybe you've started into
product management and you're trying to
figure out how to be the product manager
that you want to be
um so it's hard enough just to to get
your foot in the door so get your foot
in the door by any means necessary I
mean obviously legal and please be a
nice nice human but you know get
yourself into the door and do a good job
even if it's not exactly your ideal job
you will learn an immense amount and you
will meet customers and colleagues that
you love no matter what company it is
and no matter if you're doing it like
the right way
um having a good attitude and
um you know putting your best foot
forward is always good
in my opinion to build experience and to
learn and then from there you can start
to figure out how to up level
so finding Community is really important
I joined all three of these communities
um I ended up being an organizer at mine
the product San Francisco it was a
really great experience
I was just at the women in product
conference last week products that count
is another Meetup that I went to
relatively often
um these are great communities they you
know might seem kind of like I don't
want to network I don't want to you know
but honestly it's really helpful you'll
meet people you can collaborate with who
can open up doors for you
um you also meet friends who will geek
out about product management or you know
even commiserate about you know
different things that you might be
struggling with
another thing that a community can help
you with is finding a mentor so
mentorship has been shown through data
to be prop like one of the most helpful
things that you can ever get in terms of
career progression so or even college
graduation so if you could get a mentor
as early as possible to help you
you know who's been there who's been in
your shoes and who really sees you and
sees what's valuable about you and can
help you navigate that is super
important mentors are very hard to come
by because they're busy people they have
lives they have jobs but most people's
is also shown through survey data want
to be mentors like 90 of people want to
be mentors so just keep trying until you
find somebody who works for you it's
very important as part of your career so
you can do that through
um you know honestly emailing people on
LinkedIn call the amount of people you
can go to communities people Grove the
company that I used to
um to work for it was actually a college
career center basically where you could
log in and find folks who'd already
signed up to Mentor you a lot of
colleges have that platform or similar
ones so you can find mentors lots of
different ways
Google it try to figure it out go get
yourself a mentor
all right next up step steps 10 and 11.
so know the score I guess what this
means is you know once you're into into
your product management role you're
starting to kind of feel yourself a
little bit you start to be like all
right this is hard I get this like
you're learning which is great
um the problem is there's a bunch of
other talented people out there who are
also very good and who are also
um learning and growing as well so
you're gonna need to keep yourself sharp
especially if you're interviewing at
some of these more
um kind of like coveted roles and and
jobs all product manager jobs are
amazing they're just some that tend to
be a little bit more desired um so
you're gonna have to up level yourself
so and that's true if you want to be a
startup founder as well
PM jobs entrepreneur jobs especially in
the tech World require a lot of skills
primarily technical design and business
no matter where you come from if you're
an engineer if you're an MBA if you're a
designer you're going to have probably
one of these three where you're going to
be weaker in and I do encourage folks to
try to shore those up it's going to be
hard it's going to hurt
um but it's good you don't have to you
know necessarily go back and get a CS
degree but it's really helpful to shore
up some of your weak spots and just get
some improvement because it'll help you
day to day and you'll make you feel more
confident I have a few resources on the
right that I've used I use Udacity
before I worked there it was fantastic I
really it really helped me learn
technical skills you can also go to
Coursera lynda.com code academy is
really great if you're starting out
learning technical skills especially
programming go to Khan Academy there's
so many different ways to do it on the
left here is more about business
strategy so strategory is one of my
favorite blogs
um it's all about market conditions and
all about you know what's happening that
matters in the world of tech
um and and why in Hindi has great
analysis on it this one on the bottom is
uh this a a former
associate of of mine who worked at the
first startup called Tristan Cromer Who
does these really great and really
practical
um uh
pieces on experimentation so whether
that is if you're starting from
completely from scratch or a B testing
what when to do which experiment in
which context really helpful and very
practical so highly recommend that
but the takeaway from this is whatever
your weekend you should probably try to
up level yourself and there's a million
resources out there so organize yourself
and get it done
practice interviewing so this one is not
very fun nobody really likes doing this
but it's really important because other
PMS out there are doing this and if you
don't practice it actually is kind of
obvious so I've done a lot of interviews
especially at Twitter and it's very
noticeable if people are just kind of
winging it when other people have
practiced so you know read cracking the
PM interview read decode and Conquer I'm
a big fan of Lois Lin you can go to his
slack community and get interview
Partners which is really helpful
exponent is another one that I've used
that's like a interview practice site
there's other great ones Candor is
another one there's a lot of these out
there
um this one is free these are relatively
cheap
um
if you're interviewing for some of these
more coveted jobs you're going to need
to practice so I know that sucks but
it's true and while you do this it'll
make you a way better product manager
like you'll bring back some really great
new ideas new strategies to your current
job so definitely do this
all right last step
um so this one is honestly about kind of
bringing it all together so you've
upskilled yourself you've practiced you
know you've been at the PM role for a
while you've tried out different things
you have a perspective of what's
interesting to you you know how to
synthesize information you know how to
lead you've got all of it
if you don't know how to bring it
together with a story it's still not
really going to go anywhere so learning
how to tell your story about where
you've come from what's interesting
about your perspective you are unique
you are amazing and you can do it but
you also have to figure out how to
really bring yourself to light so it's
not you know it might sound kind of
annoying that you know I don't want to
have to sell myself but it's not really
selling yourself it's really just
understanding what is amazing about you
and allowing that to shine so you can
you know how do you learn how to
storytell you practice you practice over
and over again so how do you do that
maybe you go through multiple interviews
maybe you practice out loud with your
partner there's a lot of ways to do it
you could do things like what I'm doing
right now get on some webinars start you
know leading start mentoring yourself
like mentoring other people there's a
lot of ways to learn to storytell but it
it is important once you've especially
when you're trying to up level learning
how to tell your story in a way that is
compelling to other people that shows
your perspective shows your passions and
your expertise
is is extremely important
all right so that is the presentation so
just in summary the first steps are
about starting your own thing creating
something from scratch get something off
the ground
when you're after that or even during
that finding your perspective find a
problem that really matters to you and
start researching it start understanding
what you know makes the customers and
users tick in that world what Solutions
are out there what could you do
read think discuss read the news watch
content discuss what discuss what
matters about what it is that you're
consuming with other people or write
about it
become an expert just have fun with
Things fall in love with them be
passionate just get involved and be
become an expert it really helps you
stand out in the crowd to have something
that you're independently passionate
about
um when you're trying to up level
definitely oh I'm sorry when you're
trying to break in my advice is to find
a startup and if you can't break in
directly as a PM join a startup in any
role that is relevant to your passions
and then
do a good job you know be I think
definitely make sure that you know you
are in it for the job that you get but
then after a while
you can probably move into a product
manager role as long as one's open and
you are showing expertise
um in the domain
from there get a mentor try out
different PM roles join a community
um you know start to kind of get a feel
for
um by working with other folks in the
community with a mentor or trying out
different roles like what path do you
really want and how can you get there
and then when you're really trying to up
level teach yourself those skills that
you're lacking it is important to
compete with your peers who are very
smart people
um that you have at least short up your
weak spots
um and that also goes for practicing
interviewing do it it's not fun but it's
really helpful so do it and then
storytell bring it all together what are
all the things that you've done and all
the things that you've learned
um who's made you into the amazing PM in
person that you are today and help your
interviewers see that help them
understand what's amazing about you and
why they absolutely have to have you on
their team to build the amazing product
that will thrill and excite and solve
problems for the users in the real world
so that is it thank you so much for
attending this webinar and best of luck
in your Pam career